hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
before we begin we wanted to cover a few
housekeeping items
for any common technical issues please
refer to the help widget located at the
bottom of your screen
if you have any questions during the
webcast you can submit them through the
q a widget
questions will be answered immediately
following the presentation
any resources and links provided from
today's presentation can be found in the
resource list
an on-demand version of the webcast will
be available approximately one day after
the webcast
and can be accessed using the same
audience link that was sent to you
earlier
hello everybody welcome i'm ganesh
ananti narenin
i'm a principal researcher at microsoft
research over my career i worked on a
broad set of areas in systems and
networking
ranging from mobile computing to big
data systems
to wide area networking and offline
video analytics which is the focus of
this webinar so today i'm going to talk
to you
about our video analytics platform that
we call rocket
that's a plugable extensible platform
that runs across the edge
and the cloud and why are we doing video
analytics
frankly because there are cameras
everywhere
all the way from government enterprises
being deployed for surveillance for
traffic optimizations
to private enterprises in private
buildings in retail stores
all over the place a startling piece of
statistic
is that there is a camera deployed for
every eight people
in the us that's the scale that's the
the scale at which we're talking about
here
and what do people do with these cameras
today a variety of applications are
actually powered by
these cameras the first set of
applications that you know
some of this that we ourselves have
worked on one is on deployed by
restaurants where they want to be
informed when a car is pulling in
or when people are walking in so that
they can either dispatch ushers
also like pre-make certain food items
retail stores are another class of
applications which is also where video
video cameras play a big role people
want to know
both from a historical perspective
what's like the heat map of people
moving around so that they can help with
product placements
as well as sort of like real time
intervention when they see certain
customers that need help or assistance
smart cities and urban mobility is
another vertical we've actually
ourselves
done a lot of work in smart cities and
urban mobility
where smart you know video cameras are
used for both traffic congestion
as well as traffic safety let me tell
you a little bit more about
traffic video analytics which as i said
has been a driving application
for our project on video analytics we
call the work
video analytics towards vision zero and
for those that are not familiar vision
zero
is an initiative that started a couple
of decades back
in sweden with the objective to
eliminate pedestrian and biker deaths
that occur due to traffic fatalities and
during the time we were starting with
the project
we reached out to the nearby city of
bellevue in washington
where they had just signed on to the
vision zero objective as well and
and they were interested in using their
already widely deployed traffic cameras
for traffic safety and traffic
efficiency
and in fact the startling statistic that
caught our eye was the fact that
traffic related deaths are among the top
10 causes for deaths worldwide and so we
were
we've entered it that hey if we can make
a dent at this if we can make a
difference to this
that would be great and and so we did a
bunch of work
uh you know especially in terms of using
the rocket video analytics stack
towards analyzing the bellevue traffic
cameras where we get a bunch of things
for traffic volumes for traffic planning
and so forth
and let me show you a short video of the
kind of stuff that
that video analytics can power in the
space of traffic video analytics
microsoft research is working on a
multi-national road traffic safety
project
called the vision zero initiative
started in sweden in 1997
vision zero aims to eliminate fatalities
and serious injuries on the road
here we show how a microsoft edge
computing device can save
lives by analyzing a camera feed in real
time
when a person in a wheelchair is
detected on the crosswalk the device
resets the pedestrian lights timer
allowing the person in the wheelchair to
safely cross the street
as part of this project we partnered
with many cities
all across both america and canada
and this helped us understand both the
real use cases
that they had as well as the challenges
towards achieving this solution
are we quite glad about the fact that
this project won
two major national awards towards the
fact that it was
uh it was towards the fact that it was a
visionary project
uh in showing what can be done in terms
of traffic safety and traffic efficiency
with video analytics
so to summarize our goal
is to democratize video analytics
and what that means is that we want to
do video analytics
that is on live videos so it functions
in real time
it is low cost in that the cost of
running it is not prohibitive especially
if you have to run it 24 7
while at the same time the outputs are
still accurate
a bit of context on the fact that the
real reason why we got interested with
video analytics
was the fact that there was so much
excitement around what the vision
community had achieved in terms of how
accurate the results they could produce
for
object detection object classification
and so forth and
and we just wanted to bring that out to
the general public and and at that point
we had seen that
the cost of doing it was really high and
it was not something that was
suited for running in real time and so
that in a nutshell
is our objective towards democratizing
video analytics
this is the rocket video analytics stack
right on top as you can see in orange
are the fact that there are various
application verticals some of it which i
just explained in the early part of the
webinar ranging from smart
cities to connected restaurants retails
and so forth
and and and the the the framework allows
for expressing the needs of this
application in a very generic fashion
so you can construct a bunch of modules
put together as a pipeline
that then gets passed down to a pipeline
optimizer
the pipeline optimizer does its job of
picking like the best
choices and applications that is needed
this is act into a query optimizer if
you would in a database
that is then passed down the layers
where
resources are allocated to it and then
this pipeline
is run both across the edge and the
cloud
and finally what we do is we take the
outputs of these live video analytics
and pipe them to a database so that if
you want to do any kind of historical
analysis later on
that is something that you can go and do
without
spending too much time and it can be
interactive
the cool part is is uh is that you know
while i would finish the first part of
the webinar
the second part we actually are open
sourcing this code
and my colleague would be giving you a
walkthrough of how to use the code and
the various components in the rocket
video analytics stack
so so to just give a larger perspective
of what the video analytics stack
exposes you know you do see the software
stack
right in the middle there but then on
top we make it easy
for you to have very common
functionalities that all video analytics
applications want
which is a way by which we can do easy
filtering and getting all the moving
objects in a frame
how do you decode all the frames in a
video how do you track the objects
across the different frames
how do you plug in various dnn models uh
from your favorite dna execution
framework like tensorflow
and how do you put all of these together
so that you can construct your
application needs and of course
this is the basic building block and the
blocks that you see
on green on top takes these outputs from
these building blocks
in the rocket video analytics platform
and then builds up higher level
applications like counting traffic
directional counts across
time how do you assess near collisions
that happen how do you get vehicle
speeds
and so forth
so today's webinar would cover two major
parts
of the rocket video analytics stack and
i'll do a deep dive off the technical
components
the first thing is how do we use
approximation
as a key tool for us in being able to
run scalable video analytics across the
edge and the cloud
and the second part would be switching
gears a little bit and talking about
interactive querying on stored video
feeds
let's get to the first part here as i
explained earlier the rocket video
analytics platform allows for users to
exp to express
their interests their applications as a
series of pipelines put together
this is an example of a pipeline where
there is a decode where there's an
incoming stream that's decoded and then
there is a set of frames that are
available
these frames could get resized you might
want to do frame sampling and not
process
all of them then you want to do some
kind of background subtraction so that
it does motion detection for you to know
if there are moving objects at all it's
a very effective way to filter out
certain frames
if two frames are repetitive and have
the same content and then
you go ahead and pass it to various you
know dnn models like
like yolo and fast rcnn and so forth
and these configurations are pretty
important like the various choices that
you make here
what's the resolution what's the frame
rate that you go to what's the object
detective model that you're going to use
they have a huge implication in terms of
of of the amount of resources that is
consumed what's the accuracy of the
output as well
this is an example of what happens with
say the frame rate
we see that with increase in in the
amount of frames that you don't process
and sample out
of course the cpu cost reduces but then
at the same time the quality also drops
and we see a similar trend for
resolution as well
more the resolution that you process at
the better
is your output but at the same time the
costlier is your processing
uh this is an example of say two you
know of one of the videos
in in the city of bellevue where we see
what the output looks like for an
object detector for two different
versions of yolo
clearly we see that tiny yellow which is
a much cheaper version of the original
full-blown yolo does pretty well
in this intersection which is which is
fairly sparse not very cluttered
however in the same city you go to
another intersection
what we do see is the tiny yellow no
longer looks very good it misses a lot
of
objects it finds objects that are on the
sidewalks to be cars and it's quite
confused here whereas
a full-blown yellow does much better
and so putting it all together you know
these various knobs that we have the
various implementation choices and the
dnns that you have
how much do they make an impact let's
look at this graph here
this graph shows on the x-axis the the
resource demand that you need for
running these these various pipelines
note that this is a logarithmic scale
graph
and of course on the y-axis is the
quality or the f1 score
and what we see here is that look at
these two points
almost the same quality of the output
but with two orders of magnitude
difference in the amount of resources
that they need
and this general trend is true for
variety of applications including a
general object tracker
a dnn classifier that you might want to
use
and and why this difference it's just
simply because it's
it's dependent a lot in terms of of you
know the kind of camera that you have
the lighting conditions at that moment
the color of the objects
and unlike sql queries unlike database
queries
there is no analytical model that is
available for us to construct these
resource accuracy profiles
and not only do we have to get these
we also then have to execute these
pipelines across this hierarchy of
compute options that is available
there's computer available on the camera
there's compute available in edge
clusters which is deployed by these
enterprises
and then of course there is the public
cloud as well and there is the network
connectivity across them
in fact i would encourage you to check
out this this fun article that we wrote
a couple of years back
where we were predicting that real-time
video analytics
is actually would be the killer app for
edge computing
so to summarize the problem statement
here we want to pick the query
plan to go with the database analogy
that says what are the various knobs
choices that we have to make what are
the implementation choices what are the
dnns that we use
and then place these different modules
across the hierarchy of clusters
and we have to do them jointly
so this is the problem statement more
specifically
decide the query plan and placement and
what we want to do is when there are
multiple such video pipelines that are
running
we want to maximize the aggregate
quality say the average quality for
instance
and then run them across this
hierarchical setup
and of course there are diverse quality
requirements for these different
applications like for instance
the the tolling application might not
really have strict latency
considerations but
would need very high accuracy because it
would not be acceptable if
you get told inaccurately traffic lights
for instance is an example of something
where you need
moderate to high accuracy but you do
need to happen it within a second or two
amber alert could be an extreme example
it needs not only high accuracy it also
needs to be super real-time
so the framework allows for setting the
various requirements that these
applications have
to provide an overview of our solution
what we do is that when a query or a
pipeline comes in what we do first is
run it through a profiler what the
profiler gives you
is this resource quality profile note
that we've seen this resource quality
profile
gives us the opportunity to make very
good choices in terms of how efficient
we can be without dropping accuracy too
much
and then of course as i said different
applications have different requirements
for what the quality is that they want
so these queries uh you know all are all
passed to a scheduler
the scheduler of course is the brain
that goes ahead and
and decides which uh decides which
implementation choices to make for each
pipeline and how to run them
across the hierarchy of clusters
this leaves us with two main challenges
the first one is
how do you efficiently generate this
resource quality profiling
note that i had said unlike sql queries
we don't have analytical models that are
available for
for video pipelines the second
is how do you schedule
for for aggregate values of quality and
still do placement at the same time
so the first part is of course done
offline and the second part is the one
that is done
online on a continuous basis
so let's first move to the resource
quality profiling
this is an offline operation where the
objective is the following for every
you know query plan so to speak which is
every combination of configurations that
we have
you know say for this specific
resolution this specific frame rate
this specific dnn choice what's the
resource consumption going to look like
what's the quality of the output that's
the profile that we need that the 2d
graph that i basically showed you
of course a trick here is a key problem
here is that
the the quality is something that you
can measure only with a ground truth
and for a general query in the wild that
just comes in there are no hand labeled
data sets available
so one thing that we do is we use data
results from what we call a golden
configuration so this is like the most
expensive configuration that you can
choose
we use that as the gold standard and
then measure the results of all the
other configurations against this golden
standard
so what we primarily do during the
profiling process is to have
a targeted search for the most promising
of query plans
where we don't where we don't
necessarily profile all the options on
the entire video set that we have
but we try a small set we try to see if
these configurations are promising if
they aren't we let it go
and if they are promising we try it on
more videos to see how that goes
uh but the but one one challenge in this
is this profiling is not something that
you can just do upfront once and then
you're done
what we really need is periodic
profiling because the video content
keeps changing
there are times for instance say in a
traffic video where there are a lot of
cars
there are other times when there are not
that many cars if you recall the very
example that i gave earlier
when things are not very cluttered
something very lightweight works just
fine and we want to identify and exploit
those opportunities
this is an example of say what would
happen due to the value of say periodic
profiling
in this graph here on the y-axis is is
what is the resource consumption
that we need and the x-axis is is is
roughly the accuracy of the outputs that
are produced
clearly we want it to be more in the
bottom and more
to the right and and the the set of blue
and the red dots clearly will show you
that doing just a one-time profiling
uh ends up with worser options than
doing something much more periodic
so that's great this shows the value of
periodic profiling
however i do a little bit of a cheating
there in that in this graph
i have actually not included the cost of
profiling
when i do include that look at what the
results happen
we end up with much worser uh you know
values in the fact that the cost due to
smarter choices
is all wiped away for the fact that
we've paid additional cost in doing this
profiling to get these choices at all
so in a nutshell now the key challenge
in this is to reduce the profiling cost
i wouldn't go too much into detail but
we use three
key techniques here the first one is
temporal correlation where if a certain
configuration
is bad then it continues to be bad for a
long time
likewise if a configuration is good it
does stay good for a little bit and so
we don't have to keep profiling
them all the time so this helps us
exclude a vast number of configurations
out of the picture
the second one is that organizations
rarely deploy cameras standalone they
deploy a fleet of cameras say in the
city
in the building in the store and so
forth and there is a fair bit of spatial
similarity
in the profiles of these configurations
what we've seen is
is we can cluster these cameras and do
the profiling for just one of the
cameras and pass this profile to the
other cameras and that holds just fine
this dramatically reduces the cost
and the third is the independence of
these configurations where
we've seen empirically that these
configurations tend to operate
independently so we don't necessarily
have to do the combinatorial thing of
profiling all the possible combinations
of configurations
but can do profile these configurations
individually
i encourage you to check out our sitcom
2018 paper for more details
on this profile so
essentially the profiling uh goes ahead
and as i said generates this 2d plot of
the quality versus the resource demand
you know very smart about the fact that
the profiling has to uh you know not
consume
too much resources but then at the end
of it now we end up with this with this
2d graph which then has to be passed to
the scheduler and often there is a lot
of options that are now available
so now what we do here is that to make
the scheduler's job easy
what we do is is select you know the
pareto boundary
of these these options like for instance
take these two points the green point
and the red point
note here that the red point is strictly
better than the green point
in both dimensions there's no trade-off
here in both
quality and resource demand the red
point
is better than the green point which
means that
we don't have to consider the green
point at all as long as we have the red
point
this is a point that we call pareto
optimal it's a concept from
economics and if you generate a boundary
of all these pareto optimal points
you get the pareto boundary and so the
non-pareto
plans are no longer required for us
because as long as we have some point
uh on the pareto boundary we're good
enough so that's the thing that we then
pass to the scheduler
in the next stage and this note that
this dramatically reduces
the amount of options that the scheduler
now has to deal with
so this brings us to the second part of
the talk in terms of the scheduling
itself and and note that this is a
multi-resource scheduling problem i've
been sort of like presenting these
graphs
for uh for simplicity as just cpu
resource or just
a compute resource whereas whereas this
is a problem in a hierarchy of clusters
that includes not just the compute
but also the networking connection
between the cameras to the edge to the
cloud
and so what we do is we use the the idea
of a dominant resource demand
for each combination of configurations
and placement
and this is a concept that actually was
uh was was roughly now
generated during the the time when big
data analytics was happening
for multi-resource scheduling
and so so what this allows is that
uh you know the dominant resource demand
it avoids
lopsided drain of any single resource at
any location
so the dominant resource demand uh you
know make sure that that we are using
all the resources at all these these
various locations
in an even-handed fashion and so one
week once we get this this dominant
resources
then we essentially use a pareto band
that ensures that we don't have to go
through this entire search space
but only have a small fraction of the
search space
in terms of evaluation we've evaluated
our system
with a workload that consists of traffic
cameras
and surveillance cameras these original
frame rates varied in
in terms of uh you know how much high
risk they were what the frame rate etc
was
and we used a variety of queries which
we again you know we've seen were
important for
for lots of video analytics applications
and just to summarize what we see was
that we can get considerably better
accuracy
than competing schemes and despite the
various approximations that we made to
the scheduling heuristic
we are still pretty close to what an
optimal would do
so this finishes the first part of the
talk where i showed you you know video
analytics can be done across the edge in
the cloud
and how approximation is a key tool that
we can use
now let's switch to to using these the
fact that we can do
efficient live video analytics to say
how can this
power interactive video analytics on
stored videos on historical videos after
the fact
and why do we want to do it simply
because video recordings are ubiquitous
it's done
everywhere and you know being done in
terms of highway systems at homes
even on our phones and and today you
know
it's it's great that we have these cnns
these convolutional neural nets
they do enable accurate query for
instance you know traffic planners in
the city of bellevue might want to know
find all the trucks in the video
yesterday in the last week
because this helps them know how the
streets are being used and so forth
and if you want to do it it's great you
know this is kind of what the outputs
would look like it gives you all the
trucks
but you want to do this today it
is slow it takes a lot of time and it is
quite expensive
and sure so why so let's fix these two
problems you know we don't want it to be
slow because then it's no longer
interactive and there is enough to show
that interactivity is quite important
and we don't want it to be costly either
so what can we do about this
well one way to make the queries fast
and not
not them be slow is we can analyze all
these videos at
in just time just on the live videos
let's analyze them
and plug them into a database but this
is a very expensive solution
partly because enough studies have shown
that
a lot of the videos never get queried so
this end up being
a bunch of wasteful expenditure
expenditure that's close to 400
a month per video stream
of course at the same time you can
address this problem by just doing
nothing at ingest time
but analyze all the videos at query time
but this also takes a lot of time for
like a month long video it can take
many hours and month long queries are
quite common for planners
it can take many hours and this is
hardly interactive so so this is kind of
what we want to provide
which is enable low latency query low
cost querying and at the same time
not lose the fact that we still need
high accuracy results
and we wanted to lose our large
historical video data sets
graphically speaking this is kind of
what we want to look at if you look at
these two axes
the ingest cost and the query latency
what we want to be doing here is that
of course we want to be doing better on
both of it which is closer to
to to the you know to the left hand and
the bottom for both these dimensions
and even ingest heavy scheme where we do
all the work at interest time falls
here which case it's a great you know
kind of query latency
and if a query heavy thing where we do
all the work
only at query time when the user asks
for it falls here
we ideally want to be here this is kind
of where our goal is
and towards achieving this goal there
are three main objectives which is
let's provide a low cost indexing
let's still make sure that we achieve
high accuracy and low latency at
query time and finally as you can guess
this is a system that that needs us to
make these hard choices these trade-offs
between ingest cost and query latency
so first let's get to low cost indexing
uh of course we all know that you know
we that
dnn compression is a pretty big uh
thing these days we can take pretty
complex dnns
and compress them to make sure that they
provide sort of like roughly the same
functionality
but this end up running far fewer layers
and and so forth and
and this is considerably so we can just
go ahead and say that
when these you know frames come in and
we get these objects
instead of running these expensive cnn
in just time and plonking them into an
index
let's just run these specialized
compressed cnns
this is considerably cheaper
however these chain ends are seep cheap
for a reason
they're cheap because they're also
considerably less accurate
than these expensive cnns like take this
example
where we're running a classifier that
says what kind of object
is it so what we see here is you know an
expensive cnn would sort of like
produce the outputs by ranking what it
thinks the object is
you know starting from most likely to
least likely like for instance if you
take a certain image and say that hey i
think it's a truck
then i think it's a moving van and so
forth
this ordering is not going to be the
same for the cheap cnn
because the cheap cnn would think that
hey it probably looks like a moving van
to me
so the outputs may not really match if
you want to look for the the rank
one in terms of what the output is but
if you do look at it the best result
from the expensive cnn what we've seen
empirically
is is within the top k results
of the cheaper cnn and for a very small
value
of k so this gives us a great
uh you know leverage in terms of how we
can use these cheaper cnns and fix the
problem of accuracy
so instead of generating a simple index
let's generate a top k
approximate index here where what we do
at ingest time is we take these frames
we of course run these compressed cnns
and then now go ahead and put everything
that's in the top k
into the index and so now when we put
everything in the top k into the index
when someone
is querying now this is not just an
index lookup as we were doing before
but now you'll have to get these outputs
from the top k
index now we'll run it through this
expensive cnn but now that we're running
it through a
far lesser number of frames the
expensive cnn has to do far lesser work
than before
and after that we we return those frames
and
and so this way we ensure that you know
while there is
uh uh you know well there is low-cost
indexing
we also you know we also produce highly
accurate results because of the fact
that we have expensive the expensive cnn
at query time
this of course leads us to the next
question which is okay it's great but
how do we achieve low latency because
we've just
added a bit of additional work at query
time
earlier we just had to look up the index
now we have to run it through this
expensive cnn
to get precision
so to address this non-trivial work that
we have to do at query time
what we do is we use clustering based on
the
extracted features of these dnns
uh you know just a little bit of context
you know before the fully connected
layers in these convolutional networks
there is a feature vector that gets
produced
and and usually what we've seen is that
images that have the same feature vector
are mostly
visually similar as well and this has
been shown in multiple studies
in terms of you know prior work so
essentially what we do here is
we take these these uh you know we take
these these feature vectors and we
cluster them
and so so what we do here is in this in
this flow that i had before
first we cluster the objects and then
produce the top k results
and then only on the centroids of these
clusters do we run these expensive cnns
note that the number of centroids are
far lesser than what we had otherwise
so this is kind of how you know the the
whole
the the the workflow looks like in terms
of both achieving cheap
indexing highly accurate results and yet
not too much work at query time
hence giving us low latency
uh of course there are also tradeoffs
that you can do between the ingest cost
and query latency
like for instance what's the cheap cnn
that you pick
perhaps you can pick a slightly more
beefier cheap cnn and then that might
give you a lower value of k
which means you might end up doing less
work at query time so these are things
that a system operator can set
depending on the choices they make
so for our results you know we use the
same videos as before the traffic and
the
surveillance videos and note that we
strive for target recall
and precision values of 99 percent
and so this is kind of what the solution
looks like i mean this is where our
ingest heavy baseline
is and this is where our uh
you know a query heavy baseline which is
one of the recent work uh from from
prior work that we have
and so we end up falling here which is
actually
substantially cheaper than in just heavy
baseline
and much faster than a query heavy
so with our design you know remember
this price point before that we have of
close to 400
a month per stream we can actually get
it down to single digits
and likewise for a five hour footage we
can do it in a handful of minutes
to go through a five hour footage
let me show you a demo of the system in
action
right now
okay so here is the
demo of focus
as we can see we can select different
kind of video that we want to query
in this prototype system and different
class
so let's say i want to query this string
video
that we call sit hard and we want to
query a object that's
dock because as a ct planner we may want
to know how many dots
and what kind of dogs show up on this
street
and we can see that this video it has
sometimes people going walking around
and
bicycles and different objects
um so if we don't have focus we just
have baseline
then we do query we click run
then the query will go on um
and then as we can see that we need to
check
many frames basically uh around 10 000
frames
before we can get the results which is
going to be very slow
as we can see on the other hand
if we have focus uh we can do the same
query
but now we select that we use focus
uh which generate approximate index
and so we can save a lot of query time
so now if we click
run then we can see that
the query latency becomes very fast
it's only three seconds and you only
need to check
uh 100 frames then we can return
results we can see that there are two
segments
and in this segment we see dog and the
other one
we also see dogs it's pretty cool
and we can also do different kind of
query for example if we are interested
in
uh bicycles in a different video
and we can select this and
we can again do this query
again because of the design and focus we
only need to check very few frames at
query time
so we only take two seconds to return
the results
we can see the bicycles moving around
pretty accurate and if we come back to
the baseline
it's still running it's going to take a
much longer time
since we don't want to really wait i
actually run this query
uh before this recording as we can see
that
uh at the end of this query of baseline
we overall need to process more than 10
000 frames
and the latency is more than four
minutes
so compared to focus there's only like a
few seconds
there is two orders of of magnitude
improvement
and we can see the resent results are
exactly the same
so these two segments with dogs
so we can see that white focus
is a much better option than baseline
i also want to say that this is part of
the code that we are releasing so
youngsha would also be showing a demo
of this indexing in action uh of course
some of the techniques that i didn't
talk about today but we actually quite
excited about
is you know as i said at some point that
uh
you know organizations organizations
deploy a fleet of cameras together
how can we use them together for video
analytics
uh privacy is a big thing we are we're
quite cognizant about
so how is it that we can do private
video analytics both on the edge
and on the cloud and finally this is not
all just about video
dnn inference but we also you know have
projects that go on to update these
models on these edge device continuously
so to conclude the first part of this
talk i had shown how approximation
is a very handy tool for us to run video
analytics across the edge in the cloud
i had shown how we can use this live
video analytics as
as is to to pipeline well into
interactive querying of stored video
sets
as well so in the next part of the talk
i'll hand it over to my colleague
yanchow shu who would be explaining
about the rocket video analytics
platform that we've open source
he'll show you how you can get set up
with it how you can play around with it
and and how you can use it for your own
applications
thanks ganesh hi everyone my name is
ryan chao and i am a senior researcher
at
microsoft research so i'm gonna walk you
through the
code of rocket and show you a few
configurations of the pipeline
so at this point we have some good news
to share with you as ganesh mentioned
microsoft rocket video analytic platform
has been released recently
and everyone can visit the url below and
clone the repository from github
and the link also contains instructions
on
setting up the environment this rapport
puts together a hybrid
edge cloud video analytic platform which
is built on c-sharp on a car
and the cool part is that it allows
tensorflow dn model plug-in
and gpu and fpga acceleration as well
as container docker containerization
and interactive querying for the after
the fact analysis
so many of these components in this
platform
are key building blocks for video
analytic applications
including traffic counting near-misses
detection
vehicle speed estimation crowd control
and so forth
so functions you may find useful in this
code include a line based alerting
and a selective dn cost for efficient
gpu and fpga usage
and it also features edge and cloud
partitioning
in which you can run cascaded costs to
cut cloud dns for example
the microsoft cognitive services or
azure machine learning
or shift it to edge only mode if the
network is not available
and also we have an interactive after
the query after the fact querying
on stored videos for example you may
want to find
all the frames which contains the red
cars from the previous week
so next i will walk you through the
project and introduce
five pipelines suited for different
real-world scenarios
the microsoft visual studio is
recommended ide
for rocket once you install this
visual studio you can simply click
vap.sln
to launch the project
so in visual studio on the right hand
side you will be able to see 14 in total
projects
under the solution vap and each of these
roughly corresponds to a module in the
rocket platform
for example there is a project called
decoder
and in this decoder.cs you will find a
function called get next frame
which returns the next frame of either
live video streams or a pre-stored video
file
and similarly in the dark net detector
you will find a frame diane yolo.cs
where there is a function called detect
which use darknet yolo object detection
model
to generate a list of yolo tracking
items
provided an image or a frame from the
video
and the main program the cs file
is it sits inside this video pipeline
core
projects
so in line 143 you will be able to see a
big while loop
in which each frame of the video
is going through different modules
which module this frame is going through
is configured
in a file called app.config so in this
file
we have pre-compiled six different
configurations
for example if we set the value of the
pipeline config to 1
it means every single frame of this
video
will be analyzed by the dark knight
yellow v3 model
to execute this code there are basically
two options
you can either do it in visual studio in
the debug mode
or run and run it in a command like tool
like windows powershell before running
that in visual studio
you need to pass several application
arguments
those arguments are defined at the very
beginning of the program.cs file
as you can see here they are in total
five arguments you need to pass into the
application
the first one is a video url so the
rocket pipeline
accepts both local video files like a
mp4
avi file or live video stream like rtsp
stream
and the second argument is a line
configuration file
so in rocket project we use line
to define an area of inches where you
care about this object
and the following two factors are
sampling factors
and resolution factors respectively
so the sampling factor determine how
many frames
you want to run on this video for
example
if we set the sampling factor to 2 it
means we will drop
half of the video frames in the file
and the resolution factor decided how we
gonna downscale this video
to speed up the processing
and of course you need to specify what
are the categories
you are interested to be detected in
rocket
so here we have a sample video put into
this repository which is named
sample.mp4
and there is also a sample line
configuration file corresponding
with it and here we set this
down sampling rate to 2 which means we
drop half of the frame
and we don't change the downscaling
factor
which is set to one by default
and we care about all sorts of vehicles
including
cars minibus minivans and trucks
so the first pipeline that we are going
to show
is a configuration that generates alerts
on objects
in the area of interest as i mentioned
before in rocket
we use a line to define the error of
interest
so this sample video we included in this
repository
is from a traffic camera in a total of
five minutes video
there are four cars and one bicyclist
moving down the road
in this scenario we draw a line near the
top right corner of the scene
to detect all objects moving downwards
this snapshot of this video shows where
the line is
in the sample line configuration file
so in this file each line
corresponds to a line you draw on the
scene starting with the name of the line
the id of the line and four values
defining the coordinates of the of this
line
and the last parameter is an overlapping
threshold
so now let's go back to visual studio
and set this
pipeline value to one and run this
pipeline and see how it goes
after loading yolo models rocket starts
processing the video
by running dn inference on every other
frame
as you can see even if we set down
the sampling factor to 2 the average
processing speed is at around
20 fps which is insufficient for
real-time video analytics
if you go back to file explorer you will
find an output folder named output or
in which you will find all the detection
results
from this dna model
as you can see at around frame id 1300
the first white car shows up which
triggered this line
and captured by this dark night yolo
model
and 22 alert was generated
switching back to this folder you will
find
all the alerts caused by different
generated on different frames
since running the dn on the entire five
minutes video takes a long time
i'm just going to show you the
pre-generated result
of running yo on this video
as you can see all four cars
are successfully detected although it
may take
tens of minutes
so to speed up this detection rocket
platform also features a background
subtraction-based detection module that
can be used as an early filter
compared with dna inference background
subtraction is much cheaper
and can be running on cpu at a fairly
high fps
so now let's switch back to visual
studio and see how the fps goes
when we adding this background
subtraction based detection
as you can see the average fps goes as
high as 90 fps
because at this moment there's no
objects so no dn
is caught and it's purely running
background subtraction on cpu
at the time when a car shows up the
background subtraction triggers the dn
and the dn finds a car and send the
result to a cloud database
so even considering the latency of
sending the data to a cloud
database the average fps remains at
60 which is double the speed than real
time
as the application runs i'm going i'm
also going to show you
how to run a db query to get the
detection result from the cloud
so for example this is a simple gui
to send this query to the cloud database
we have already set up a cloud database
as well as azure blob storage to store
all the detection images
if you run a query to find all cars
being detected during this time period
you will get the results in half seconds
with a total count of 21 so all the
images
as well as with as well as the metadata
of the detection
will be fetched immediately without
processing
tens of hours long of the video
similarly all the detections can be
found in this output folder output all
and the third pipeline we are going to
introduce
is detection object with cascaded dns so
on top of pipeline 2
we are going to add another dnn before
calling this heavy dn
full-fledged yellow so in many cases
we can run a cheaper dm which could
already give you a sufficiently high
confidence so in that case
only if the confidence is not high
enough we will not proceed to call this
heavy dn
so let's set this pi plan value
3 which corresponds to this cascade at
the end
here two models are loaded which are the
tiny yellow v3
and the full-fledged yellow v3
background subtraction based detection
keeps running on every other frame at
roughly 100 fps
if we find some movements on the
foreground
it will firstly call the tiny yolo model
as long as the chip model has a
sufficient high detection confidence
the heavy model will not be triggered
so here in this output folder the output
ltdn
contains all the detection results from
this tiny yolo model
here you can see it detects the first
white cars and the second black cars
while the app is still running
the third car and the fourth car will
also be detected at a later point
so the third car comes and some new up
some new detection results are generated
and if you switch to this output
cascaded dn folder
you will see the result of heavy yellow
object detection model
which as you can see are more precise
and the confidence score is much higher
so in pipeline 3 we have three modules
sitting on the edge however
this may not be feasible especially when
the
heavy model becomes bigger and the
number of video streams
increases so here in pipeline 4
we move the heavy dn detector to the
cloud
making the shared service to multiple
azure analytic pipelines
so in our azure cloud we have created an
azure machine learning service and
deployed a darker image
with tensorflow radnet model
the azure machine learning azure machine
learning service can take advantage
of cloud fpga accelerators and provide
grpc and tensorflow serving predict apis
of course you can always deploy a cloud
model
using a customer docker based image
so many of you have already been using
docker and containers
so for those of you who are new to
docker let me say a few words about the
extremely popular technology
so in short containers allow developers
to package up
an application with all of the parts it
needs
such as libraries and other dependencies
and ship it all out as one package
by doing so developer can rest assured
that the application will run on any os
both linux and windows regardless of
customized settings
that machines might have that could
differ from the machine used for writing
and testing the application so for
example
you don't need to worry about if.net
core runtime
is installed on the hostel os
another difference in pipeline 4 is we
switch the local light dn
detector from a yolo
b3 model to a tensorflow model
the rocket is designed to be compatible
with different pre-trained tensorflow
model
here as you can see in the visual studio
we use a fast rcn model
based on rasnap but you can freely
change it
to another model from the tensorflow
model zoo
now let's set the app config value to 5
to run this pipeline 4.
as you can see at the beginning the
tensorflow model is
pre-downloaded to the local device
and then the gpu is initialized
so you can see when a car shows up
rocket continues to call
the tensorflow model and once the
tensorflow model detects
there is a car without sufficient
confidence it will proceed to send a
remote call to the azure machine
learning service to verify whether it is
a vehicle of interest
so in the output folder
you can see the result from the cloud
azure machine learning service which
successfully detects all this object
as a kind of vehicle
so the last pipeline that we are going
to introduce today
is the container plus agent cloud split
so different from pipeline 4 here we
also containerize
the local pipeline of running background
subtraction detector and light dn
detector
in this way this pipeline can be
transplanted to a different
hosting os for example linux mission and
being executed there
so here i'm going to show you a remote
session
of running this pipeline on linux
machine sitting in azure
i'm not going to show you how to build
this docker image
because it may takes tens of minutes
instead
we have already previewed this image
and put it down to this linux mission
so this is the docker image that we are
going to run on around the docker
around the rocket pipeline to run this
pipeline
we simply mount this disk
and also similarly to run that in visual
studio we supply
the videos the line config file
and downstairs down sampling factor and
down resolution factor
so after downloading and extracting the
tensorflow model
the app is running on the linux mission
because it's a cloud
device so the cpu is much more powerful
than the laptop we are demonstrating
here so as you can see
as a result the average fps goes as high
as
90 fps
so you can configure the pipeline to
send this result to a cloud database
as well as some local storage service
and here i'm going to log into this stp
into this device and see the outputs
in the file system
so here as you can see there are also
pencil detection results generated in
this output our folder
so this concludes the webinar these are
just
five sample pipelines of the rocket
platform
so you can configure and put together
your own pipelines
and also reuse the output of the
existing pipelines for further analysis
of the video content so we hope you get
a sense of how
in general the techniques look so more
materials and update
can be found at the rocket project
website
we look forward to your thoughts
questions and bug reports
thank you
uh hello everybody this is uh ganesh
from microsoft and
we've been switching over to the the q a
part of the the webinar
so let me start with uh you know some of
the specific questions
uh that were asked about the the first
part of the the techniques that were
presented
one was the ability of the profiler or
the system to
to cope with you know real-time video
streams
and what is the latency for processing
uh each of the video frames
so so you know upfront i would want to
state that yeah the main
you know part of the video analytics
platform is to be able to process
live video streams which means that if
it is a 30 frames per second video
stream the budget that we have to
process
each video frame is about 33
milliseconds
so so that is something the framework
automatically takes care of
uh you know even when we're doing the
profiling to find the configurations
uh we only keep configurations uh at
which we can you know sort of like go at
the the required frame rate and there
would not be any buffering of the frames
as such
so for instance if we do have a heavy
configuration
then we would appropriately make sure
that the frame sampling is chosen so
that
you know there is no buffering of the
frames and we keep up with the live
frame rate
um and then there was another question
on the second part of the talk around
video indexing
and video querying as to uh you know
how do we actually store the the the
outputs of the cnns
that we do during ingest and how do we
do the clustering
so just to add to the content in the
webinar
uh we would like to say that you know
all the frames that are chosen
for ingesting we run it through the
cheap cnn
uh you know of course there is an
optional aspect where we might the
ingest itself could have a frame sampler
in it but all the frames that are chosen
for ingest is run through
a cheap cnn and once the
outputs of the cheap cnn is available as
we saw in the webinar as well there is
uh there's both two kinds of outputs one
is the actual you know classification
itself and then there is the
uh then there is the the feature set
that is provided
so we put both of them in a database
and along with the frame id as well
and and so later on when a query is
asked then we extract it based on these
indexes
uh you know there is a a resource list
that we have and
where there is a project web page and so
we had a technical paper on this
uh you know late last year this was at
osdi
2018 where the name of the work was
focus
so so i encourage you all to check uh
the resource list
and the the paper for details exactly on
what's the schema used in this database
and how
they are extracted
moving on to the next question one of
the question asks
how does rocket you know sort of like
compare with with frameworks that are
out there
and being used for training dnns
you know like cntk tensorflow
pytorch and others so we would like to
state that
with rocket our main focus and our main
goal
was on uh was on the inference so we
wanted to take
live video streams and run as we saw a
pipeline which was a cascade of dnns
and non-dnn modules on each frame
so from that point of view rocket is
quite complementary to
many of the training frameworks that are
out there and uh
so as as we demonstrated with
plugability of
tensorflow models uh into rocket that is
available
today uh anybody can use you know any of
these
uh these frameworks tensorflow and so
forth to build new models
train new models specialize them to
their content and so forth
and then they should be able to plug
that in
into rocket more specifically in a
nutshell
if if your model is already compatible
with
with tensorflow execution today you
should be able to use that uh
inside of rocket straight away so so
you know while right now rocket is not
exactly focusing on the training part of
it
uh we hope that we you know models that
are trained today
in things like tensorflow can
automatically be plugged in
and uh you know going forward something
that we do have
in our pipeline is is to think of
extending
this compatibility beyond just
tensorflow to
other frameworks like pytorch as well
and broadly be
able to have integration with onyx
models
for those that are not familiar onyx is
a is a general uh
of you know way by which you can
represent models
and uh you know many major frameworks
and organizations already support
ingesting and running onyx models so our
hope is that with that it would be
even more uh you know of a general story
where
anybody can build their models converted
to onyx
and then they should be able to run it
inside rocket so that is something we do
have in our plans
and more broadly with training uh there
is work that we're doing right now where
you know while there is one time
training that does happen
uh what we are trying to do is is sort
of like have this continuous
model where you know we all know that a
one-time trained model
is isn't always good enough because
there is
there is change in the scenes uh as such
you know for video streams we can see
that over time
there is change in the the video data as
well so there are new
there's new classes the new objects so
so we need to adapt our model
continuously so something that we are
also working on
is uh is a continuous adaptation of
these models
over time you know incremental learning
or continuous training
of these models so so this is something
we should hopefully have more to report
on in the next few months
uh moving on there was another question
on uh
on how much effort does it take to sort
of like extend
rocket uh to verticals beyond smart
cities
and urban mobility which which was sort
of like used as
uh as example use cases in the
presentation
uh this is a great question and uh you
know
while we used smart cities and and urban
mobility
as a as a as a motivating framework and
a driving sort of like application
for for a work on video analytics
the framework as such is uh is in no way
tied to any specific
use case or vertical you know rocket is
a framework that
is designed to be broadly applicable to
all kinds of
application verticals including
connected cars
you know connected restaurants and and
you know
internal uh you know enterprise
buildings and so forth
and we ourselves have done uh many
pilots and engagements
that that go beyond just uh smart cities
and urban mobility
and uh so so our hope is that you know
the
you know this the second part of the
webinar where we presented the ability
to put together
multiple pipelines you know construct
these pipelines by putting together both
uh you know cpu-based opencv modules
and you know the cascade of many dnn
models a hope is
that is something that uh you know
people would both
uh use and you know check out from the
github use
and be and apply it to many sort of like
you know application scenarios
uh you know as we discussed
hi this is ryan chao i also got a bunch
of
questions that i can answer so the first
one is
in early parts of the presentation
someone asked if rocket is compatible to
run
on both linux and windows and i hope
the code walks through in later part of
the webinar
give you uh give everybody a sense of
how to set up
rocket on both linux and windows so the
short answer is yes
and uh if you visit the github web page
the readme file should also provide
step-by-step instructions on how you can
set up rocket on both environments
and also uh another question is
um someone asked about uh the benchmark
results of rocket
because the the first half of the talk
talks about this
video analytics efficiency and
scalability
so um roughly speaking it's based on how
you construct the pipeline
so for example the pipeline runs more
efficiently if
it has cascaded models and early
filtering for
moving objects just to put things into
perspective
so for example on a media 1080 gpu
we can support 10 streams at 10
fps for scenarios like car counting
and of course the accuracy is
largely dependent on the video content
and in most scenarios that we worked on
10 fps is sufficient for getting a
reasonable
accuracy and if you dial down the fps
numbers to
say one fps and the number of concurrent
streams
could go up to as high as 100.
hey folks this is ganesh again uh moving
to my uh
you know favorite question that that i
get every time this work is presented
is what is the impact of democratizing
video analytics
on privacy as such you know clearly
cameras being everywhere has a cost in
terms of
of you know us being monitored all the
time and so forth
and and this is this is a great question
this is uh you know sort of like a
tricky question and importantly a
question that we pay a lot of serious
attention to
um you know something that we didn't get
to cover today in the work but you know
we didn't
make a brief mention of it is that we
take the privacy
seriously both uh while video analytics
happens
in the cloud as well as uh it happening
in the edge so in the cloud we have
solutions that we are working on
that make sure that you know these video
analytics modules run securely
inside enclaves so that both the cloud
provider
and other co-tenants do not see what is
running as well as what is the video
content
so so this ensures that the video
content is
only something that is visible to the
person running the analytics
and on the edge side we we are actively
working on solutions where
that allow for some kind of access
control where
it allows for users to both whitelist or
blacklist
uh you know things or object categories
that they would like
even being shipped out off the edge as
we know
as part of as you saw in the webinar
edge is a big part of to our story on
video analytics
so we want to ensure that anything
that is that is getting out of the edge
after the analytics
is only run it is only something that
the users have authorized
be shipped out off the edge
so so of course privacy is a is an
evolving story and we
and and but but this is something we
take very seriously and we already have
many solutions in place
uh to ensure that you know private
content does not get out of the edge
neither is it leaked to other cotenants
uh in the club
okay so i guess this uh wraps up the
the webinar as such
uh you know we strongly encourage you to
check out the
resource links that are there with the
webinar the project webpage
uh please go to the github link
hopefully you'll be able to check out
and play with the code
as well and uh yeah we look forward to
your feedback
both on the code as well as the other
technical uh aspects
of the project the video analytics
framework as such
thanks everyone for joining bye